[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
protéger les épargnants payer moins et
gagner plus
115 milliards d'euros c'est le montant
supplémentaire épargné en 2020 par les
français par précaution du fait de la
crise sanitaire selon la banque de
france
dans ce contexte les sénateur albéric de
montgolfier et jean françois husson ont
présenté le 6 octobre 2021 devant la
commission des finances un rapport sur
la protection des épargnants
il en ressort que le marché de l'épargné
française se singularise par
l'application de frais de gestion élevés
qui ampute la performance offerte aux
épargnants
il s'agit d'un enjeu majeur pour le
pouvoir d'achat car toute baisse des
frais se traduit par des gains de
plusieurs milliers d'euros à long terme
face à ce constat les sénateurs
recommandent d'encadrer plus strictement
certaines commissions et d'accroître la
convergence réglementaire européenne
il souhaite aussi que possibilités soit
donnée à l'épargnant de faire jouer la
concurrence
dans cette perspective les auteurs du
rapport envisage de rendre obligatoire
le référencement de produits indiciels à
bas coûts dans tous les produits
d'épargné fiscalement avantageux afin de
garantir aux épargnants la liberté de
choix
il souhaite également faciliter la
transférabilité des contrats d'assurance
vie
enfin les rapporteurs juge pertinent
qu'un plan d'épargne-retraite reposant
sur des produits à bas coûts soient
proposés aux épargnants par une entité
publique à l'image de ce qui existe au
royaume uni
cela permettrait en effet d'accroître la
compétition
au delà de la performance les
rapporteurs ont également vérifié la
qualité de la supervision du marché de
l'épargné
de ce point de vue les rapporteurs
estiment que la france est dotée d'un
dispositif de supervision à la fois
rigoureux est suffisamment flexible pour
s'adapter aux évolutions du marché
sur cette base solide la commission
propose de renforcer le contrôle de
certains intermédiaires et produits
ainsi le champ d'intervention de
l'autorité des marchés financiers
pourrait être étendue au contrôle des
investissements défiscalisés dans le
logement locatif tandis que la
réglementation des cagnottes en ligne
gagnerait à être renforcée
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport de la commission des
finances
[Musique]